so we are going to talk about floating
bodies of convex compact n dimensional
sets in the dimension can be anything
two three five hundred and seventy
thousand four hundred and twenty six
whatever but for the purpose of today's
talk let's just stick with N equals two
that is let's just look at such sets in
the plane so let's look at some examples
for instance the circle the square or
the triangle so those are convex compact
sets in the plane so what does that mean
compact means that the set is bounded
bounded means that there is no direction
where you can wander off to infinity so
for instance if we looked at something
like so right and we'd be allowed to
continue here then we could march off to
infinity here and that is not allowed
now what's the other ingredient that we
have it's convex so what does that mean
it means that whenever we take two
points in the set in question like for
instance here in the circle and we look
at the line segment that joins the two
then we stay completely in the set the
same here we'll take two points we look
at the line segment that joins them we
stay completely in the set saying here
take two points that are in the set we
look at the line segment we'll stay
completely in the set so for instance
what would not be allowed is something
like so right here if we take that point
and that point and we look at the line
segment that joins the true then we are
outside the set so for such convex
compact sets let's call them K we'll
look at the floating bodies so let's
take K convex compact so everything that
I am talking to you guys about can be
done in any dimension as I said but
let's stay in the plane so we'll have
here our K convex compact and then we
also give ourselves a parameter Delta so
that's just a number typically think of
Delta being small and then we'll take a
line and if we were in our dimension
three instead of a line we would take a
plane and if we were in higher dimension
we
would take what is called a hyperplane
but will stay in the plane so we'll take
a line L and then we'll take a line such
that it cuts off a set of area Delta
from K so then we'll look at the
intersection of this line with the body
K so we look at this intersection and
then we'll take the midpoint of this
intersection and then we'll take another
line L that cuts of Delta we'll look at
the intersection and we'll take the
midpoint and we'll keep doing this so we
look at all those lines look at their
intersection take the midpoint and then
we'll look at let's draw it in color we
will look at the we trace out the curve
of these midpoints and in that way we
obtain a set inside K so this red set is
the floating body let's give it a name
the floating body of K let's call it K
Delta bar the why's it called floating
body it's called floating body by the
Archimedean principle we know that an
object floating in water so if you have
an object and here is the water surface
to an object floating in water has
always a set of equal volume above the
water surface these lawns that you drew
each time you were snipping off like a
delta how many of these lines do usual
infinitely many all possible lines that
we can draw that chop off Delta my first
instinct without having seen this done
would be that all you do is make like a
miniature version of the bigger set
that's not what happens no that's not
what happens and we will see that when
we look at when we compute actually
those for the various examples then we
will see that it's not what's happening
let's do it so for the circle that's
easy so here we go let's say the circle
has radius 1 then what do we have to do
we'll have to look at all lines L that
chop off a set of area Delta and we'll
have to take the midpoint of the
intersection so because the circle has
all the symmetries what will end up as
our floating body
again a circle so we'll end up with this
circle here which has now radius of
course more than one and one can compute
it it's actually 1 minus 1/2 3 over 2 to
the 2 over 3 Delta to the 2 over 3 so
that's the radius of this floating
circle let's look at our other example
which was the square and let's put it in
such a way that it's centered at 0 and
has side length 2 so here is 1 and here
is 1 so if we want to get the equation
of the floating body or the boundary of
the floating body let's put the x axis
here the y axis here and then we can
show that actually it's enough to
compute the shape of the boundary of the
floating body just in the first quadrant
here by symmetry we'll get the other
ones and we can show ok its shape is
something like so and then by symmetry
we can complete the picture so the
floating body of the square will look
like so and we can write down let's
write down the equation for this part in
the first quadrant and then this is
simply Delta over 2 is equal to 1 minus
x1 minus wife
that's not know it's not a circle in
there and but what we also see is that
it's not like you know the original
shape we started with it actually looks
different let's look at the last one of
our examples that we put up there which
is the triangle we draw the floating
body then we will get something like so
so that is the floating body of the
triangle so that looks very strange now
very different from the other ones in
particular the floating body of the
circle in the square they were giving us
again convex objects whereas this is
certainly not convex at all and that's
actually something we are not too happy
about and we want to change that so how
do we come upon this strange shape for
the triangle
well we remember what we have to do to
get our floating body is this operation
that cutting of sets of
area Delta with our lines and taking the
midpoints so for instance if we took
this line we would get that midpoint and
then if we moved with our line like so
always cutting off Delta and taking the
midpoints then we would be moving along
this curve here and we would end up well
now my picture is not super good we
would end up this line giving us as a
midpoint that point here and then if we
kept moving then the line would go down
here and up there and that then means
that we are actually moving backwards
along that curve here till we hit this
point where the at this point is the
midpoint of the line that shop's of
Delta and is parallel to the site of the
triangle and then we go here and move up
there so as I said here we'll get
something that is not convex and that is
not what we like because we want to use
these floating bodies as a particular
tool no it's not a mistake it's just so
happens that yeah that comes out using
this definition where we take those
midpoints so the fact that the floating
body is not convex is fine it's just not
good for you it's just not good for our
purposes for the purpose we want to use
to blow floating body for which is to
investigate the boundary structure of
convex sets but it's perfectly fine
perfectly okay is it easy to predict
what the floating body will look like
it's not always so easy to predict what
the floating body will look like one can
get any idea how it might look like what
is in general difficult is actually to
compute the equation of its boundary to
compute that exactly this is difficult
it can be done like for this example
here in the plane and it can be done for
most examples in the plane but typically
we are interested not just in you know
dimension 2 or 3 but in really very high
dimensions and there it is difficult to
exactly compute it but at least when the
Delta is small we can pretty much
determine how it looks like very well
there was nothing wrong a priori with
you know floating body for the triangle
losing the dupe our definition but for
our purposes it's not good so we want
because we do want to stay in the realm
of convex bodies and what we will do is
to get something that we then call the
convex floating body so this was brought
up around 1990 and it goes as follows
again let's just look at the two
dimensional situation so we have again
our convex compact set okay and again
we'll take lines L that chop off Delta
and now we will take all such lines that
chop off Delta that is we take away
Delta same as last time but we don't
bother about taking any midpoints we
just chop off Delta and then we'll look
at what is left after we have chopped
off Delta and what is left is a convex
set and that is the convex floating body
let's give it a name let's call it K
Delta how have you drawn that line if
you haven't gotten midpoints to guide
you it's just you chop off and look at
what's remaining like for instance if
you let yourself skate again by you know
object floating in water then we know
the water surface what's above the water
surface is always something of equal
volume then if you rotate this thing
around then the same volume it would be
the same equal volume above the water
surface and the floating body is just
that part that remains always under
water so it never got to breathe or it's
something that always stays wet if you
want so that what we do here will
construct this wet part so this part the
new floating body is basically all of
the points that never got a chance to be
in Delta yes so to speak young never got
a chance to be beyond there now if we
want to compare this floating body this
convex floating body with the one that
was given to us by depois then we see
that if this dubov floating body
a delta bar we called it is convex then
actually the two coincide then K Delta
is just equal to this K Delta bar so for
this example of the circle we would just
get the same circle for the example of
the square will just get the same object
like so and what would we get for the
triangle well for the triangle we don't
have that this dupa floating bodies
convex but this convex floating bodies
convex and what we'll get is simply
these things here without these strange
parts so that would be our convex
floating body for the triangle and for
every possible convex compact set mm-hmm
my floating body will always turn out
convex I can't construct a shape that
won't give me a correct yeah mm-hmm good
sounds fun good yeah it is
so there's a convex floating body but
you might be thinking well what's the
point of that what does a mathematician
use this for the answer to that is in a
second video links are on the screen
description all the usual places thank
you for watching area because we all
take so this is K Delta area of the big
one - area of the small one so what
remaining is this one I call this the
crust we take the crust good I like that